tomorrow is scheduled to be the last day
of the Supreme Court's current term
after that the only two cases they'll be
considering our pool noodle versus pool
noodle and mouth versus margarita but
but before they go they've got two
decisions left to deliver including this
one the biggest one we're waiting on at
this point is Hobby Lobby this is the
challenge to the administration's HHS
contraception mandate that's right Hobby
Lobby America's one-stop source for
glitter and googly eyes could soon also
be America's leading source of landmark
binding legal precedents hobby lobby's
owners say that Obamacare's
contraception mandate conflicts with
their Christian faith which means the
whole case boils down to one fundamental
question can a business a for-profit
corporation claim it has freedom of
religion do for-profit corporations have
religious right to corporations have
religious liberties or to just
individuals our corporations a person
able to exercise religious rights no no
thanks to the Citizens United ruling in
which corporations were deemed to have
the same free speech rights as people it
is now a possibility they may get
religious rights as well and if they do
it's gonna be pretty easy to guess which
religions they'll choose aren't stone
brothers obviously Jewish although they
do sell bacon and are open on Saturday
so let's say more culturally Jewish than
observant meanwhile Ben and Jerry's
clearly Buddhists although not too
Buddhist or they'd be selling new points
of cookies and Nothingness and Taco Bell
I'm presuming is Hindu because you know
there's no beef in those things
in the case in the case of Hobby Lobby
the company's founders are the devoutly
Christian green family and to be fair
their faith has led them to do some
genuinely admirable things and we
believe that the principles that are
taught scripturally or what we should
operate our lives by and so it naturally
flows over into the business the company
pays full-time entry-level employees
ninety percent above minimum wage and
devotes a very large portion of its
profits to a broad array of charities
well that's fantastic although I
wouldn't get on too high a horse about
the moral high ground of your company
given that a solid chunk of your
customer base our Etsy sellers buying
yarn to make handmade cock-and-bull
cozies and teenagers purchasing
top-quality glue for huffing oh oh
really Bobby you're into model
aeroplanes are you build one for me
right now you can't can you boy you're
killing your mother you're killing her
Bobby but here's the thing
while hobby lobby's owners are seemingly
sincere in their beliefs their sincerity
isn't really the point
just as it isn't the point with the
other company which is also part of this
decision it kind of stove a would a
company that makes parts for kitchen
cabinets is owned by a Pennsylvania
based Han family they are Mennonites
that's right in addition to Hobby Lobby
the government is also being sued by
Mennonites
or as I believe they're called the diet
Amish the Mennonites they're
cabinetmaking pacifists who argue that
they don't want to pay for something
that could take a human life but under
that logic that is why I personally
refused to pay for Mennonite cabinets
because Jason Bourne could conceivably
beat someone to death with one of us
what these companies are arguing is that
the sincerity of their beliefs should
allow them a line-item veto over federal
law but government is not an ala carte
system where you can pick and choose
based on your beliefs taxation is more
of an all-you-can-eat salad bar you
don't get to show up and go look I know
it costs 1099 but I'm only paying 750
because I have a moral objection to
beets because because of course you do
they're an abomination of a root
vegetable they're bland flavor and slimy
texture is the front unto the Lord if
you can persuade enough people of that
then you can have a referendum to remove
beets from the salad bar in the future
but until such time you're paying for
those beets because everyone has
their own version of beets I don't want
my tax dollars paying for abortions I
don't want my tax dollars going in
support of this Israeli policy I don't
want my tax dollars spent to support
this mosque I don't want my tax money
being used to buy illegal drugs a shrimp
running on a treadmill that's what's the
best use of my tax dollars right now I'm
sure Pam and Kansas doesn't want her tax
dollar spent on some of the things that
they're spending especially Mexican
prostitutes
okay I can see your point on the
prostitution but those fat shrimp need
help you think they like being called
jumbo they're crying inside if you
really want to be treated like a person
corporations then guess what
pay for things you don't like is what it
feels like to be one
in fact if corporations want to be
people they should have to take the
rough with the smooth for a start
companies should only get to have the
average lifespan of a person 79 years 75
if they're based in Mississippi Oh
female companies you only get to make 83
cents on the dollar sorry Wendy I guess
it's just that Burger King must have
worked harder and that's just the big
stuff there's also the little annoyances
of being human so mr. peanut I hope you
enjoy attending your friends shitty
improv shows and Starbucks get ready to
have your name spelled starburst on your
coffee cap and for GM who've admitted
some responsibility for the deaths of a
minimum of 13 people I've got some bad
news for you people who do that
generally don't get off with a
fine